so i am uh for better or for worse
sort of continuing my maya culpa i have
completely been underestimating
the relevance power importance and
potential
of this q anon wing of the republican
party i talked about this i think it was
on tuesday or wednesday this week i
think tuesday
and every day i am learning more about
the reality that um we probably should
have paid a little more attention to
this to begin with there's a new vice
article pointing out that
q anon already has 19 candidates running
for congress in 2022.
david gilbert writes that as the gop
becomes more receptive to the conspiracy
theory
more of the cult's followers are running
for office
with 18 months to go before the 2022
midterms q anon supporters are already
seizing on the gop's embrace of the
conspiracy theory
and growing their hats throwing their
hats in the ring for a seat in congress
so far 19 people who have publicly shown
support for the q anon conspiracy theory
have declared their intention to run in
house and senate races across the
country
according to a media matters
investigation recall our
revelation i guess we would call it our
discovery
from earlier this week that based on new
polling
one in five americans on average yes
more in some parts of the country than
others but one in five americans on
average
believes at least one of the three major
human on conspiracy theories the one
about the child pedophilia
uh inspired by satan the one about uh
there may need to be a violent
a sort of a takedown of the centers of
power in order to save humanity or the
country or whatever
and what's the third one um oh the third
one is yeah like the the conspiracy of
you know the elites that are secretly
controlling and manipulating
deep state type stuff those are the kind
of three major branches of q anon
conspiracies
20 percent of the country believes at
least one of those and we are seeing
this reflected not only in voters
but we are now seeing it reflected in
candidates now the
logical fear would be if 20 percent of
america believes at least one of these
conspiracy theories
and you've got what will probably by
november of 2022 be dozens of candidates
who believe this stuff running
the 20 that believe in that stuff are
gonna go and vote for the candidates and
we're going to have more q anon
in the house of representatives rather
than less i think that we would
safely say right now marjorie taylor
green is a q anon person
um in some sense matt gates is a q anon
type
i don't know what the full like is
madison cawthorne q anon is lauren
bobert queueing on i don't know
but when you see 19 people
already running with a year and a half
to go that's not good
that's not good the article in vice goes
on to say all but one of the candidates
are running as republicans
the single anomaly or anomaly both are
acceptable pronunciations
is mindy robinson running as an
independent in nevada's third
congressional district under the patriot
party
of nevada banner like 14 others on the
list robinson was a candidate for
congress in 2020
and like all but two of those she lost
oh okay this says the two candidates who
won
that are q are lauren beaubert and
marjorie taylor green
both up for re-election um the number of
q and on supporting candidates is likely
to increase as the 2022 election
approaches
in 2020 the final tally of q anon
supporters
who ran was 97 according to media
matters
for america like many of the candidates
on the list bobert and greene
have sought to distance themselves from
the most extreme fringes of the q
on movement despite repeatedly
displaying support for the conspiracy
on social media and in video interviews
this is a real concern now
i don't know that we could have done
that much more
to stop this um before
now in the sense that there was not
really the sense that this would be
significant
and so if you can't convince people that
something's serious
how do you get them to activate against
it i don't know but now we know it's
serious and now we know that it's real
and one of the things i'm most
interested in seeing
in these upcoming trump rallies trump is
restarting the maga rallies and he's
getting the old 757
tuned up and getting work done so he can
start flying into rallies one of the
things i'm curious about aside obviously
from seeing
what donald trump's sort of emotional
state is the interviews with the
supporters at these rallies it's not an
election year 2021 it's not even a
midterm election year it's just a random
it's a non-big election year
what is the mindset and the tone and the
mood and the perspective of the people
that go
to a june 2021 trump rally
and that i think will give us a sense of
how prevalent
this cue movement is within the people
that are going out to support trump
there's a real question as to is the
queue movement more of a stay home and
type stuff up on the computer type group
or is it more of a go out to the rallies
type group
i fear that it's the latter and that
they are going to really make their
presence known and felt
strongly uh during the 2022 campaign
and every indication now that this is
far
more serious far more serious than we
imagined
i've often had trouble falling asleep
when i'm staring at my computer
or phone screen late into the night and
that's partially because
blue light from screens suppresses the
sleep hormone melatonin
and blue light can generally cause
things like eye strain or even headaches
but it has not been an issue for me
since i was sent a pair of blue blocks
glasses
which block out blue light unlike all of
the low-quality mass-produced blue light
glasses out there blue blocks are
actually evidence-backed made under
optics laboratory conditions
these are the blue light glasses you can
trust and they have something for
everybody lenses for daytime lenses you
wear before bed
they have a prescription version
non-prescription readers
over 40 different frames to choose from
these are the ones i picked out i
never have problems with it anymore it's
great go to blueblocks.com
pacman or click the link below and
you'll get twenty percent off when you
use the coupon code pacman20
and there's free shipping worldwide on
orders over a hundred and fifteen
dollars